welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and today our
guest is Professor Dean Karlan a
professor of economics at Yale and
president and founder of innovations for
poverty action or IP a professor Collins
research interests include poverty
issues in developing countries and in
particular financial innovations and
microfinance programs aimed at the poor
he uses field experiments to learn what
social policies work what do not and why
professor Carlin also does research on
fundraising voting education and
behavioral economics
welcome professor Carlin thank you good
nice to be here so let's begin with
talking about innovations for poverty
action what is it and how did you come
to found it
sure so innovations for poverty action
is a nonprofit organization whose
mission is basically to first learn what
types of ideas out there in the world
are effective in addressing poverty
problems and social problems more
generally some of that work involves
creating new ideas that are then
simultaneously tested in the field to
see what is their effectiveness some of
those are really about taking ideas that
are out there or they're
well-established but that we don't have
clear evidence on whether they work or
not and a big part of the mission for
innovations for poverty action is about
doing the the hard work beyond the
beyond the initial idea to really
establish whether something is a good
idea that can work in many contexts in
many locations rather than just having a
few case studies that say AHA this
worked once here and so it really pushes
hard to really understand how we can
make the research and translate that
research into scale-up programs that
will affect many many more people not
just the individuals that participate in
a pilot
okay so what actually caused you to
found it was it something in your
research that you were doing what was
the impetus so the impetus is it's more
the other way around actually it's it's
I it's so the easier way of explaining
that is explaining why I'm a researcher
in the first place so a sixteen sixteen
years ago I was an intern for a
microfinance organization in El Salvador
and my work there had nothing to do with
research but what struck me the most was
how little we really knew about not just
what the impact was of this program but
why this program was working the way it
was working why was it's making group
loans why was it making loans of the
size it was making why was it making
loans of the interest rates that it was
charging and and so and and what was it
that we were expecting the clients to
actually do with these funds and in
terms of what they are what types of
training programs did they have access
to to teach them how to run micro
enterprises and there was a lot of these
types of questions were not being not
being explored and there was really no
evidence that this organization could
look to to help guide it in making
decisions about how to run a program
okay and so that's the reason I went
back to graduate school was to do
research on this and then basically went
in graduate school what I discovered was
you know academics really hadn't been
doing this type of research either and
so this is why I started doing this type
of research but then you know if all I
did was the research it wouldn't really
satisfy the reason why I was doing the
research in the first place which was
getting that information back into the
hands of the practitioners of the
policymakers so they really knew what
they could do with that you know what
what is the evidence that's out there
and how can they use that to make better
decisions and so a large part of ipas
mission is about the the communication
the dissemination and the scaling up of
successful ideas the the stopping of bad
ideas mm-hmm so let's talk a little bit
about the primary objectives of IPA
mm-hm so the the primary objectives in
some respect can be put into two two
piles there's there
the the production of knowledge that
includes creating ideas and testing them
and then there's the scale-up the
communication side of of IPAs mission
we're young so all of the work so far
that is that we can really talk about
very concretely is really more about the
production of the knowledge and there's
you know we're starting now to have some
success stories to be able to do the
scale-up type work that that we were you
know created in mind to do but it's not
then the the lion's share of the work
that the organization has done so far
we're now building our capacity to
answer into those types of projects ok
can you talk a little bit about some of
the success stories sure so one that is
that I find very exciting is really one
of the most first-order questions that
you could ask in the world of credit for
the poor which is simply what is the
impact now a lot of microcredit is
focused very heavily on micro
entrepreneurial but there's a growing
movement within within financial
services to say well why why should we
only be lending to micro entrepreneurs
maybe consumer loans can have beneficial
outcomes as well and there's a lot of
tension in this policy debate because if
you look to the United States for
instance the same lenders making these
same types of loans are often given a
lot of bad publicity because the
interest rates are high and people ask
questions about whether these are
productive loans helping to generate
income or simply kind of trapping people
into debt traps so we looked in in South
Africa which has a very different market
than a lot of other parts of the world
in terms of the credit markets for the
poor and we worked with a organization
it was a for-profit firm that was
lending to employed individuals and
these were fairly high interest rate
that look these were fairly high
interest rate loans at 200% APR a year
so if we were gonna find bad effects
this was probably a good place to look
and in fact what we found was that the
access to credit led individuals to be
more likely to keep their jobs and what
what's key here in what's different
about what IPA does and what I do in my
own research as a as a Yale professor is
that you know whereas prior studies
would do
things like compare people who borrow to
not borrow and see their changes in
their life here we set up a randomized
trial and this is really you know at the
at the heart of my academic research as
a professor and also the research that
others through IPA are involved in and
so we worked with this lender to set up
this randomized trial where some were
randomly given credit and others were
randomly not of people who applied for
it for loans and so it had very positive
effects this was not to say that I think
the the you know the arguments have now
been resolved by any means and in fact
we need to see replication of this type
of project so that we can know under
what context can we can we take these
results to the bank no pun intended and
really believe that even at these high
interest rates that you know allowing
people to borrow and encouraging this
type of borrowing can lead to beneficial
outcomes okay moving to another area of
your research behavioral economics you
developed a an online program called
stick tell us a little bit about it and
you know some of its success stories as
well sure so I think an easy way to talk
about stick is first give me kind of an
explanation of the big picture of what
what the theory is behind stick and then
tell you about some research we've done
in the Philippines as that serves as
kind of the backbone of the evidence
that we have about it okay so the basic
idea is grounded in the concept that
there are a lot of things in our in our
life that we say we want to do but that
when it come time comes time to doing it
we find for some reason we don't do it
this can be as simple as overeating as
not exercising smoking this can be even
on other things not saving enough this
could be about not cleaning out your
closet this can be about voting you say
you're going to vote with the election
day comes and something comes up and
you're busy and you decide not to vote
and so the basic idea is that the there
are vices out there in the world that we
actually might prefer for the our vices
to be more expensive so we would like
dessert at a fancy restaurant it cost
$100 so that I can go to a fancy
restaurant order a healthy meal and not
be tempted by dessert because it's gonna
cost me $100 and I'm not gonna spend
$100 on cake right and so there are
people that would probably prefer
restaurants that have pricing structures
of that nature or that when you walk in
you could say the maitre d which menu
would you like and you'd say give me the
one that has $100 prices for desserts
please and $20 for everything else and
there people might actually prefer that
and so the idea behind stick is a way of
institutionalizing and facilitating that
type of pricing scheme for people if you
want to make your vices more expensive
you can't actually do that in a
restaurant you cannot go to 7-eleven and
ask them to simply make the candies more
expensive you can't go to the gym and
just ask them to drop the price or pay
you to pay you to work out but you can
set up contracts that are basically
create that exact incentive scheme for
yourself and so in the Philippines for
instance we did this with a rural bank
where we took the world bank offered
clients the opportunity to open a
savings account and they put money into
that savings account that they were
spending on cigarettes so the idea is
they're taking this money that they were
gonna spend on cigarettes and instead it
goes into a savings account and then you
agree that in six months after six
months of depositing money in a savings
account they take a urine test if they
fail that urine test well then they lose
that that money and that money gets sent
off to a local orphanage so it still
does go I didn't but if they if they
pass then they get their money back
now what's beautiful about this from a
policy perspective it's a win-win we
actually mobilized savings at the same
time that we got people to stop smoking
and it was wildly successful 30
percentage the increase in likelihood
that people stopped smoking was 30
percentage points which is unparalleled
to other smoking cessation interventions
and the other project we did in the
Philippines was on savings we did this
one five years ago and in this setting
all we did was something very simple we
just gave people access to a savings
account in which they couldn't access
their money until they reached a goal
and the idea there was would people
actually prefer to not have access to
their funds would they prefer the
illiquidity and they didn't get
compensated for this it wasn't like a
certificate of deposit where you get a
higher interest rate it was just the
same account you had before but now if
you go to the bank and ask to withdraw
your money they tell you no right so do
people want to restrict their future
choices and the answer was yes 28% of
the people that were offered this opened
their account and their savings tripled
as a result of doing it
it was also had a nice powerful effect
for on gender as a development economist
one of the things we often look at is
how how many verses women react
differently to different interventions
are out there and what that can tell us
about the the household dynamics and
what we found there was that women who
had little decision-making power within
the household after they were given
access to this account had more power
over purchase of durables in the
household so then back to stick the you
know in a lot of respects the website is
simply a manifestation of this basic
this basic idea obviously it's a little
bit more general and the website how the
website works very simply you go to the
website you say what your goal is you
say how much money you want to put
towards that goal you say who has the
power to declare you a failure
so usually here this has to be someone
you trust you don't have to have a
referent a lot of people do choose to do
their contracts on their honor but the
trick with the referee is you really
have to trust them not just to report
honestly about you if you succeed but
the trick really is finding a referee
who's willing to actually report you as
a failure right and then you say where
the money goes if you fail and that
money can go to the referee a lot of
people do that other people choose
charity and one of the more favorite
options is to choose
the what we call the anti charity so the
way the anti charity works is you're
given a list of ten politically
polarizing charities so the George Bush
library and the Bill Clinton Library and
then we took four kind of hot social
issues and we took two charities that
work on both sides work on either side
and so your idea is you supposed to
choose what you hate the most and that's
where your money goes if you fail and
have you you stick yourself so stick
very much is a manifestation of my
personal life with respect so actually
starting in graduate school I wrote a
contract with a fellow graduate student
and to lose weight and we lost 40 pounds
we both lost the weight and then we both
had a maintenance contract that went on
for many years and so I am very much a
user of this concept in my own life as
well okay and the address is at